um my name is seth manukin i teach uh
here in the graduate program in science
writing
and i'm the director of the
communications forum
and joining me today are three
stat editors and writers
to my immediate left is rick burke
the executive editor of stat
previously a longtime reporter and
editor at the times mainly in washington
exclusively in washington i was in
washington for like um
uh 17 years and then 10 years in new
york
before or after well we can get into
that later
washington and new york
okay uh
where ro i guess that would make sense
because you were also national editor
there an assistant m.a
and uh you came your most recent gig
before stat was as executive at politico
um in the middle there is uh the always
charming carl zimmer
um who uh is a contributing national
correspondent for stat
um he
also writes regularly for the new york
times
his he has a weekly column there now
called matter
uh anyways for national geographic
various other outlets
i always find this a little bit
difficult to believe and i feel like
you're counting your tattoo book which
might not
warrant counting in this but he is
technically the author of a dozen books
um
including a parasite rex evolution
making sense of life and a delightful
book on uh science tattoos which i own
and at the end there is rebecca robbins
uh who is a reporter at sac covering
money and life sciences
she previously worked at the washington
post uh the hartford current and the
santa barbara independent
and
she was also manager of the harvard
crimson
so
what we're going to do is have a
conversation
for roughly an hour and then open it up
to all of you when we open it up we
don't have mic stands today
unfortunately
but this is being recorded and we won't
be able to hear your questions on the
recording
because it's right from the soundboard
unless you ask them into the mic
so please grab one of those mics on the
table when the time comes to ask your
questions
um
so uh i wanted to start just by talking
a little bit
in case anyone isn't aware just exactly
what stat is
um so rick why don't you
take that one sure if if i may can you
just raise your hand if you read stat if
you've ever read stat
oh that's good
and we'll convert the rest of you
in the next hour
um so what what stat is we've been um
officially launched about three months
and it's a
um it's a publication online publication
with a national international audience
focused on
health medicine and life sciences and we
aim to
fill a void that that we saw in
coverage in terms of writing for an
accessible
writing authoritatively incredibly about
these issues for a
broader general audience
and
we've
we have about 50 people total including
the editorial and business
staff this was started by
john henry the owner of the boston globe
and the owner of
the red sox among other
entities
who saw a need for who's very passionate
about these issues and saw a need just
in just in kendall square seeing all
these stories are there and there's not
enough coverage and he said we can fill
the void but he wanted a
a new digital news organization that
could be more nimble than the boston
globe in
covering this so we're not
tied down by traditional
ways of doing things or ways of coverage
or ways of putting a story online so the
globe we're an independent company from
the boston globe but they're our sister
publication
and they can run
whatever stories they want of stats in
the globe and we're happy when they do
because it helps our
it gets our our stories out there and
helps with our
readership and they've been a great
partner to have we also run some of
their stories on stat so that's pretty
much what we are and we aim
to
to be a daily
readable
guide to some of these issues and
frankly we could have twice as many
reporters as we have
and
not cover all the stories that are out
there there this is as you all know this
is such a booming fascinating area we
also um we have reporters who are based
here but we also have reporters in
washington new york and san francisco
and colombia
and colombia yes
following the zika
scare in colombia and so your background
isn't in science or science journalism
right so how did that uh relationship
again yeah i'm maybe we're the last
person who should be in this job in some
ways i was um
so if anyone out there needs a job and
it's thinking about
right i was rushing from um
the office tuesday
for a day in dealing with all these
issues and rushing over to the kennedy
school to moderate an election night
party on the new hampshire primary and i
thought i'm changing back to my old
world and this was probably the first
time in decades that i hadn't either
been
overseeing
political coverage or writing the story
or something and and um
and because my whole history has not
been in this
uh world but but my interest has been
when i was at the times i had in various
jobs oversight over
lots you know all the news coverage and
one of my and i remember calling
meetings of
the science department and saying we
need more energetic report i remember
like that was i mean i knew enough to
know what what we needed and what
stories would interest people so i've
always felt
um
a good story is a good story whatever
the topic and i think i'd like to think
that i bring
to stats or the general reader's
interest in going after stories that
people want to know about and
what we've done is we've assembled some
of the most
best known and respected
people in the country people have
like carl zimmer
who write about these issues in a way
that gave us instant credibility uh to
our audience and we have for those of
you who haven't read we have this um
morning newsletter morning rounds that
you can sign up for free at statnews.com
i've heard of that yes and yes i think
you have and it comes in every more
every weekday morning at 6 00 a.m and
um to me that's a window into what we
try to do because it's a mix of the news
that we think you should know it's not
by all mean any means comprehensive but
a window into the news in this world
every morning and what's
encouraging to me is
um our open rate which the number of
people who open the email is
49
and it's been consistently 49
from laun from launching more than three
months ago and that's unheard of in the
industry that's three times the standard
for a newsletter like that which and
that tells me that
people have a hunger for a source of
this of of this news people want to read
this stuff and they're so we we're
building i think a very
um dedicated and reliable
audience i i joked and i i guess i
probably should have said this at the
outset that i've heard of that because
for about 30 seconds
uh at the launch i was working on the
morning rounds newsletter until rick and
i
both realized that it was insane for me
to try and do that and everything else
i'm trying to do seth just didn't want
to get up at five in the morning right
that also that did work definitely true
yes that was definitely true um uh so
carl um
when you signed on for stat you're at a
point in in your career where
um
you're turning down assignments for want
of time uh i know you're working on
another book you have your column in the
times um
you and i have talked a lot about the
future of science journalism and where
it's going what was it that made this
appealing to you
besides the money
well part of what made it interesting is
that um i had never really been
part of a um a publication
uh literally from the start and not only
that
that would be interesting enough but to
be part of a an effort from the start in
2015
is really interesting um because
you know you're not spending a lot of
time saying well who's our printer going
to be and what's our schedule going to
be for you know production and so on for
the the sort of the print side and all
that sort of traditional stuff i mean
basically
what was happening was that
rick
was building a site a website and
bringing in all sorts of uh interesting
people not just
uh straight journalists but also uh
people who do
you know multimedia people do video
people do animation and
uh
you know people who i as a writer could
collaborate with and um
so you know i it just was a really
exciting opportunity i mean i still get
to do
that you know that kind of uh you know
really dig into a subject
and and write about it in the way that i
always have but then i can be
just talking with people to sort of
figure out how can we make this uh
different how can we make this really
work you know how can we make this
something somebody really wants to read
on their phone for example um and uh so
so it's just been totally fascinating to
be a part of it
um and rebecca uh it sounds from your
bio like you're you have a 15 or 20 year
career in journalism
but i think that was all crammed into a
year or so is that right
but
when you'd been working for those
newspapers you were primarily working on
the print side of things is that correct
i was writing both for
web and for print but in each of those
cases these were print publications
where that was the main focus and so
coming then to stat what
what was it that struck you or did
anything strike you as being sort of
fundamentally different about
how that newsroom operates versus how
the washington post newsroom operates
yeah i think as
many
folks who've worked for both
web only and print publications probably
have experienced is that
not having to worry about filling space
or
meeting sort of artificially imposed
deadlines as a result of the print
schedule is a real uh is really
liberating and and i think
working at stat i've found that
we really can
run things
or
schedule the timing for for reporting
based on what makes the most
journalistic sense rather than
factoring in other considerations and i
think
for for me as a reporter
whose focus is
putting out the best story possible it's
been a really great experience
so
one of the things i want to talk about
is
what it what things are going to look
like not for stat but sort of for the
industry and for science coverage in
general moving forward
and it seems like at the moment stat is
doing a pretty broad range of types of
stories
um uh you know in-depth investigative
pieces in-depth features
um
video only pieces newsletters
is that because you've identified
those
as areas that you think there's
a need or there's a particular desire or
is it sort of throw everything against
the wall and see what sticks and then
modify it on the line it's really
interesting because it's it's it's been
interesting
starting from the ground up because you
don't really know what it's going to be
until it happens like we hired all these
people and we were all having meetings
about stories and everything and but i
had no idea really what the the how many
stories we'd have a day or what the flow
would be or you just don't know and
i've been surprised by frankly the
quantity of stories we've had and the
the range of stories it's more than i
would have guessed and i think it's
because
what we're focused on is
um
telling is being sort of
journalistically ambitious and telling
stories that other people aren't and our
main
focus is really
not to be boring or to do
um commodity journalism that other
people
are doing and um there's again there's
no magic formula there's no one way of
doing things we have the luxury of
experimentation
and we will see
what stories do well and not do well but
we're still so so new that we have the
luxury and thanks to
a publisher who's willing is committed
to the subject matter and to the
journalism and not just
making money immediately off this we
have the luxury of
really being focused on the journalism
and not
overthinking
um
other factors so
so we're trying to do a range of stories
everything from
investigative stories
investigative story project that took
months on clinical trials to
um what was that story
that was a story um
by charlie piller our west coast
correspondent on
looking at
there's
there's a federal law that requires
researchers to
publish
clinical trials on
the results of their clinical trials on
clinicaltrials.com i think it is gov and
most institutions
uh don't do that and break
and essentially breaking the law
everything from
stanford to sloan kettering big
institutions um i don't know where mit
was on that list somewhat but you know
and we did i'm sure yeah and we did a um
a data visualization so you could look
up your local institution and see um how
90 of the time they didn't share the
information that they were required to
share and there was a reason why this
law was
established you know you know i think it
was it all started with with when eliot
spitzer was
a.g in new york and i think one of the
some of the drug companies were trying
to get away with
um pushing
research that hadn't really been out
there i mean it's all that there's a
transparency
behind the reason for this law and that
story kind of
um
uncovered that
um
i guess what i'm saying is we do
everything from
deep investigative stories to a quick
piece today about a congressman on a
committee today vaping using like an
e-cigarette at a hearing today where we
jumped on that story
duncan hunter duncan hunter and we got
that video of it i mean what we want to
be is is
it
new friends
to a poll we did with uh we do a monthly
poll with harvard or national poll we
had a poll today on gene editing and how
people don't want designer babies i mean
we sort of try to weigh in on issues
that other people
aren't weighing into we maybe it's
because of my own political background
but we've sent people out on the
campaign trail in new in iowa new
hampshire looking for the intersection
when these candidates talk about drug
companies or or other issues related to
that we care about we want to be in on
those stories we write about drug ads
drug companies we write about um and
again as carl said sort of a range of
types of stories stories that are
video first that are driven by
by multimedia storytelling rather than
text we we've tried to do
explainers that um using and we have
animators we have people we've we've
really devoted a lot of our resources
into making science accessible and
interesting and sometimes even injecting
a little and not being afraid to have a
little fun and a little whimsy not too
much to make stories just a little bit
to make stories
um just accessible and interesting when
i was at the
one thing at the new york times i always
said this um and this isn't for me
something new to stat when i was at the
near town i said you guys are
taking yourselves too seriously you're
the area of the new york times at the
time at the time
and i would say like lighten up and have
a little fun make your stuff accessible
and there's a danger in journalism when
you when you when you don't do that and
you all three of you know how to write
accessibly and understand how important
that is to make stories readable and
interested so
speaking of clinical trial stories um
rebecca i wanted to ask you about i
think it's the first story that appeared
under the stat byline several months
before the site actually launched um it
was a piece you did about a clinical
trial can you describe that story
sure so this is a story um that i think
uh telling how i i discovered the the
story in the first place might be most
illuminating so during the summer
when we were preparing to launch stat i
spent a lot of time my time as did other
reporters meeting with people going to
events right here in kendall square to
try to understand where the stories were
and to develop sources and one of those
events that i
attended was
a panel discussion
among some executives
and
experts on social media use in clinical
trials
and so while he was at that panel
discussion uh the
most of the the discussion was pretty
boring and straightforward of you know
regulatory considerations and sort of
the
common uh wisdom on on this issue um but
during the the q a session uh one
executive raised her hand and posed a
question to the panel of experts um
about what her company a small biotech
here in kendall square should do about a
situation that was
driving them crazy and freaking them out
and that was
a
very strange thing that was happening
with their their stock price
their
stock price was zig-zagging up and down
in response they thought to
social media posts that were being
posted by
two participants in their clinical trial
and so that sort of
short exchange at a
panel discussion ended up being the seed
for a story that i did i went ahead and
talked to the patients who were
posting on twitter and facebook and
youtube
essentially in real time updating the
world on the progress of a
company sponsored clinical trial it was
for a
device that they had implanted into
their spines because they were both
paralyzed in accidents
in
this device they hoped would give them
the ability to to recover and hopefully
ultimately walk again and so the story
that i ultimately wrote i thought was a
fascinating intersection of
business of the patient experience
and of sort of the crazy world that the
social media has has created ultimately
the company's investors this is a public
company were watching the social media
posts and um
trading stock accordingly so it was a
really fascinating reporting experience
and one that i think
hopefully the resulting story
encompassed a lot of things that stat
wants to be and do
and and you have a background in
financial journalism um one of the
things i found so fascinating about that
was
it seemed to sort of um undercut the
idea of rational markets because if you
had a clinical trial with two people
those results would never be interpreted
as meaning anything
and yet here you had two
individuals
who not only were going to be influenced
by their own hopes and desires
and their subjective experiences
but other things could be going on
were you surprised when you saw that
having the effect that it did on on sort
of on stock price on something on the
bottom line in that way and pretty
significant
spikes and drops there there were some
significant spikes and drops and it
certainly was unusual and and
interesting to me and when i asked
experts about it they really saw this as
such an unusual scenario because so
rarely do you have a company whose stock
price is so dependent on say a single
clinical trial most big pharma companies
have many trials going on and many
products in the pipeline and then still
rarer is when you have a clinical trial
like this one
where
it's open label so patients know that
they're getting the
treatment and where these were the first
two human patients to ever get this
intervention so it was sort of this
perfect storm as as one analyst
described it
to me
um
carl one of the things you've been doing
a lot of is is video stories
uh um science happens is that what it's
called um can you first just start out
by describing what those are
yeah so so these are they come out
roughly every month and um they're
around five or six minutes long and
basically
the the concept is very simple i just
show up at a lab
and
pay a visit and uh obviously i don't
just show up on announcements um but you
know i what what i do do is i look for
places where
really cool basic research is happening
that
is potentially going to lead to
you know advances in medicine
and they can be all sorts of
all sorts of different things so um
uh you know we
went to
you know the first one that we did was
at johns hopkins where i went to visit a
neurologist who is developing a
treatment for stroke which is basically
having people play a very immersive
video game
with a with a joystick that's very hard
to control and the hu you basically
become a dolphin so basically he said
sit down and you are going to be the
dolphin and uh and
you know that was this great way to sort
of like take you in and and you get to
meet
you know the neurologist who's dealing
with the problems with stroke recovery
and all the shortcomings
and this new idea about how to retrain
the brain and then computer scientists
who are trying to do video games that
are going to be able to be responsive
enough for what he wants
artists who just go and hang out with
dolphins for like weeks and just do
sketches to to really make it uh to make
it work
we went to a lab uh here at the vees
where
people are basically engineering
bacteria that they want to
put into people to basically kind of
monitor or manipulate your microbiome uh
another thing we did we went to a lab
where basically they're trying to
understand death like why
why do we die when we die
in five minutes that's right yeah um you
know with cameos from woody allen and
monty python as well
but you know what they do is they study
like thousands and thousands of tiny
little worms
measuring their life spans under
different conditions
and so you know for me it's a totally
new experience which is one of the
things i like about working with stat
but it's a different way of
basically telling a story you
unfortunately i'm working with a really
talented producer named matt orr
and you know together we find a way to
get the scientists to talk about what
they do and tell their own story
and find sort of visual ways to
to
add to that um and then also they're
talented animators who can put in even
more more elements in there so it's been
uh yeah it's been it's it's been a lot
of fun and there's no accompanying that
this doesn't go along with the textual
piece as well those are basically
freestanding like i'll write a short
piece of text to just kind of like
introduce it you know so there's a
there's a section of stat where we've
been putting the videos and if you click
on one of the videos you read you can
read the text and then watch the video
and then just kind of go from there
and so what's the reaction been to those
pieces versus pieces that you've written
uh that have been written in stories
um
you know very very positive and um you
know uh
i think
i i think the scientists really like it
in the sense that like
this is something where like somebody
could just sit down in just five minutes
they get a feel for what it is they're
doing and why it would matter you know i
think a lot of scientists are like in a
lifelong struggle to explain to their
parents
why what they're doing
is meaningful you know
so these videos are i think are can can
help at least a few
children speak to their parents
but but also like after uh teachers have
told me that that they're actually like
really helpful to just like here let's
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show
students a video for five minutes and
that's going to jump us into like a
broader subject you know
we'll deal with the textbook stuff as
well but this is a way to sort of
capture the spirit
of this kind of inquiry and that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to just
capture the feel of these places and so
rick in terms of traffic um what what
types of stories are getting the most
traffic uh are they stories that also
run in the globe
um are they videos are they
um it really uh depends
on the story one thing that's surprised
me is
some of the
um
stories that that weren't like listicle
type stories have done very well one of
um it surprised you that non-mysticals
have done and non-muslims have right it
doesn't have to be a list of faith in
leadership
so um
the
um
um are our um
best
trafficked um
piece of all time was this the the
the crisper scientists the fung story
that that um sharon bakely did that was
like something like 3 000 words about
eric lander no no no no no no no no the
previous
but but here she's writing about crispr
and a scientist and it's like 3 000
words and that went through the roof in
terms of traffic and where could you
tell where that was coming from
it was translated in chinese and all
these like worldwide interests
was that was was it fueled by twitter or
by um and it was it was it was both
social and just people uh sharing the
link and sharing i mean there wasn't any
there wasn't i thought there's one
secret someone putting it up but it was
just generally just um
really
um did did very well and um
another um
um uh and so you just don't but also the
eric lander piece that
she did also did very well because i
think people like personalities and
writing about that was a piece about a
controversy about about a piece eric
lander had written about crispr that
right was somewhat controversial right
and and um
um another piece that did very well
another profile with slava epstein that
that carl wrote that did a scientist it
was kind of someone that is in is in a
household name that did very well again
because it's an interesting
personality and people want to read
about science and but
um but
so but i've also found that some of the
again some of our listicles have done
well too like the six things that um the
six cures that are the most
horrible cures that you can imagine you
know and but but we try to do everything
we do we try to give it some kind of
higher end high value added value
uh credibility to it we had um a story
that i assigned that ran today and it
was a little embarrassing
that i assigned it but i thought we
should do it and it's why
it's um trump has called you know rubio
kept calling him out for sweating
sweating sweating publicly and i said
let's let's it's it's it's in the public
discussion enough that we should explore
is there some kind of
ailment that rubio has or people that
sweat excessively and drink a lot of
water is that something we should write
so we we took it in a serious way
but not too serious and not too playful
you got to get the tone just right and i
think and we kind of slaved over just
getting the tone right and i think we
did because you want it accessible and
again not taking your tells too
seriously but also not um you don't want
to um
make mike too much light of these issues
either another story that did very well
was um rebecca's story a couple weeks
ago on their notes
all these news organizations have
um
have written and their notes is just in
case anyone does not know
oh oh theranose is the blood what what
would you do it's the it's the company
claiming that with a
tiny prick of blood it can give a whole
range of diagnostics that normally would
need several files of
and they were like on the on the on the
rise and being celebrated billions of
dollars valued at billions of dollars
and and we'll tell well you tell them
what you wrote and what sure so to
continue that background theranos was
this silicon valley darling until
this past fall when the wall street
journal started running a series of
very critical stories essentially
um
questioning the premise behind
their their promise to revolutionize uh
blood testing and diagnostics and along
with these very critical wall street
journal pieces
regulators started to
sort of
crack down on the company
so this company has been
very much
under fire for the last few months and
so there's been a
ton of reporting done it certainly is is
something that
most news organizations um and all news
organizations in this space are are
paying attention to and so the piece
that i did um
didn't didn't try to sort of do the
tried and true task of journalism of on
the ground uh reporting and that's been
being done and been done by
these other organizations in this case
and their contribution is very valuable
but my reporting here took a different
tack which was to
try to give readers a guide for
what to look out for in the next
few weeks and months
to to figure out really whether this
company this once red-hot silicon valley
upstart
was was finished whether they would
could survive and so i
tried to map out for readers what signs
to look for what bellwethers
in the coming weeks
will perhaps
shine light on on whether this company
is finished or not and that story as
rick said um
got a lot of attention um because i
think it laid out in clear and simple
terms for readers who haven't been
following sort of every milestone
development in other reporting uh what's
going on that's a good example of what
we're trying to do here there's all this
there's story after story and the wall
street journal has done a great job with
it
in driving the story but then
what we we trying to do it status or how
can we kind of zero in there and and
with added value in a way that that that
would be helpful to readers and
interesting and authoritative and that's
exactly what we did and people want to
read that and one other thing i just
want to mention that and when you ask
about audience and traffic is
we did a project on
um concussions and on this base on this
football player at syracuse who had
multiple concussions and was kicked off
the team and then he was courted by
several other college teams lower tier
lower tier but who didn't really worry
about that as much and that had not been
written before and we did a and that got
enormous attention and it was a case of
his this this guy aj's personal story
and we we followed him for
like a month or two um and
um we did a video with it matt orr did a
great video with it was like a four
minute video and what's interesting is
and this is what's cool about
experimenting in the digital age we did
the video and it did very well but then
we did a truncated version of the video
that was like 30 seconds it was like a
trailer highlights of the video that
featured
words on the screen so you could read it
at your desktop in your office so you
don't need the sound
that truncated version got over a
million hits it was just like went crazy
because and sometimes you just have to
think about how people are getting their
information these days this is something
we nest we wouldn't have thought of
before but once that happened now we're
now my next thing was let's let's do a
trailer version of science happens um so
we can experiment with and we did it
carl um i know that you uh um talk to a
lot of other science writers we're both
involved in a community of science
writers um i i'm curious about what the
reaction has been
uh
generally to
stat um and uh how people are viewing if
they're if they're viewing it as
something that uh
might portend um a different future for
science journalism uh how they see it
fitting into the ecosystem because there
has been a lot of anxiety within this
field uh you know over the last decade i
think especially over the last probably
five years
yeah yes really and i i mean i mean i
started you know like 25 years ago um i
was you know started out as an assistant
copywriter discover magazine you know
back when you actually like you know
pasted the pages on wax paper um and uh
so things have changed so much and i
would say like maybe five years ago i
was really like in a just just kind of
in a glum mood about what was going to
be happening with science writing
just because it just you know
things were drying up and just models
didn't seem to be working anymore but
um i don't know i'm
feeling more optimistic now and it's
it's things like stat it's also places
like like buzzfeed for example you know
i mean originally i thought of buzzfeed
as a place that you know had kittens and
listicles and whatever but you know then
they just decided they were going to
just open up a news operation and it
just they did it just on a tremendous
scale and then they said okay now we
need to have a science desk here and
they hired a friend of ours at virginia
hughes
who just then proceeded to hire like six
or seven people and they just started
doing great stuff
and
you know there are other places like vox
and 538 and so on like there's a lot of
places that i have a really you know
active
um science reporting going on um and so
you know
will the industry be able to support
you know as many people who were
employed in say i don't know let's pick
a year like you know 1995. i i don't
honestly i don't know
but um
but you know i don't i you know i don't
you know i don't look at it
apocalyptically you know i think i think
actually there are there's you know
there are places as places just sort of
start up
um
without being legacy people places are
starting up fresh and figuring out how
to run things and experimenting and so
on um
there are a fair number of success
stories now so that's a good transition
um
rick
i'm curious about what the business plan
is for stat uh where the money is coming
from besides john henry i know that he's
made a significant investment in it but
i also know he's a very
uh true businessman um and uh would
prefer to make money than lose it uh so
what is the the the business plan moving
forward um there's
um
we're fortunate in that john what is it
a shrewd businessman wants to make money
but also understands that um
there's
um we're all trying to figure this out
in journalism and i think what what john
would like is for this to be
an example of
a sustainable news organization that can
do it and they can make it and
i think we've had a lot of discussions
about how this might work or not work
and i think
we've come to the realization that a
couple things is one of our
our our financial
success may ride
a lot on i think this is true of all
digital news organizations these days on
um
on native content that that
advertisers put in and say you know
sponsored content and um where it's
clearly designated that this is uh not
editorial but
it's um and so native content produced
by the advertiser or just by the
advertisement not produced within stat
not produced within stats so it would be
um
like and and we've already had on our
site like johnson johnson has had some
sponsored content well they'll say you
know some little
newsy kind of looking nugget where we
say in a different colored sponsored
content johnson johnson but
it has a little more credibility to them
than just some ad that appeared on the
site so i think that's sort of
the new that's the business model for us
to sort of encourage more sponsored
content that's what we're going after
and we're getting we're starting to get
sponsors
that are very interested in that
the other thing is we're looking at
we have kind of a deep belief that
people will pay for good journalism i
think you're seeing
um the at the new york times people pay
uh
to the regular users pay money for the
journalism the boston globe same thing
so we're exp we're going to be
experimenting with different ways
politico pro or political pro maybe some
paid version of the site maybe a paid
version of this there's we we actually
don't have a plan we were discussing
just variations you could look at the
wall street journal where certain
stories you have to pay to get or not
get we could do a political pro thing
where there's like a you know a kendall
square newsletter everything you want to
know about
kansas square all the inside dope but
you have to pay money for it or not so
we're going to experiment with that
we're experimenting with um
but but but the the priority right now
is to
build the audience and
uh and develop
fans out there and is there a time frame
for when the audience building is over
and then when you ask john henry you
know seth wrote a book on john so it's
like you tell me is he how long is he
going to give up
he told he told me two more weeks
so i mean you were at the at the
event where he said well before we
launch he said the run which i keep
repeating and to him um i said the
runway is um
yeah he said the runway is long and wide
so and i reminded him yesterday that or
i told him yesterday that i was a
you know he was telling me he was just
he's he loves like newsrooms he was just
touring the new washington post
newsroom and
he said they have nespresso machines all
over but you have to bring your own pod
like they won't pay for the pods and
they save 150 000 a year by not
supplying pods so i told morale in the
washington post newsroom is sky high
so i told him that i was at the
nespresso store in boston over the
weekend i saw this
this 3800
really cool
nespresso
like machine it looked like a jukebox
like this really i said i said i really
want that for stat but i don't dare do
that until we're really
in the black and he said send me the
link i'm kind of maybe they'll give me a
deal
so i'm going to send him the link on it
but anyway so but that's the long answer
to my question is we are we're serious
about
great journalism and the belief that
john has that i have
and the hope
that we can translate great that people
will pay
for quality journalism that's our that's
our bet um and we are
trying to make that happen
so um i know that that was somewhat
ingest but uh speaking about a 3800
espresso machine um uh i know the
relationship with the globe uh is um
not a completely smooth one
uh there's been i think the globe has
essentially lost all of its science
reporters and editors
um and those positions have not yet been
filled uh um is this something that
is
being imagined as replacing what they
had done in terms of science coverage
well first i wouldn't say that
i wouldn't say it's not been smooth i
mean i i would say
um there's a grievance filed right with
the union yeah but that's that's yeah
that's a group i guess okay
as the spin i would give you is as the
is that the
um as a former media reporter here this
the spin i would give you is that
we have been able and this is true and
i'll also give you the the negative part
of it the truth is um
there's no
startup news organization that i can
think of that has ever
had this independence that we have as
our own company yet we can draw on
the platform of the globe and the
infrastructure of the globe from
everything from hr to it support
to things that we never could do on our
own we never would have been able to
start up this quickly without the
infrastructure of a legacy news
organization and i don't think that's
repeated anywhere because um in terms of
i mean you have like upshot at the new
york times and things like that but
that's not a separate self-sustaining or
trying to be self-sustaining operation
on the on the downside um
it's
it's
uh i think for people who are reporters
at the globe who
are
tied to ways of doing things that are
part of a legacy institution is as
rebecca says when you have print
deadlines and things like deliver home
delivery issues that you have to worry
about that we don't have to worry about
there's going to be a natural tension no
matter what in in the building and there
is a grievance that um from the guild
about like what is
um
stat and why are they are they replacing
us well yeah right but the reality is
we haven't replaced the the health and
science reporters we've um a couple of
them took the or left or took the buyout
they have i think a half dozen
right now that's still right for the
globe and that we
run their stories namely and some have
been like rob weissman who covers
biotech has been really helpful to us
from the start but i think i don't think
there are any more dedicated science
reporters oh in terms of actual um um
right like pure science right yeah
that's and they're there and there was
there was more than one and there were
also science editors
um and today i mean you know i it i
couldn't help but notice one of the
arguably biggest science stories of the
year
uh the gravitational waves the the
discovery of gravitational waves um the
globe ran a ap story today which i think
probably a year ago
would not have been the case right
that's separate from stat that's as
yeah it's separated from sap because
statin didn't cover the gravity
right right it's separate from stat in
that that's not part of stats
mandate right but
um to the extent that the globe science
section has been replaced by stat
i think that there's potentially a
relationship there
you mean in terms of what we could offer
well i think part of the
the reason we exist and part of
my coming to this was the editor of the
globe saying
we'd love to have more content and stat
it wasn't sad then but like we we could
use so in many ways we fill a lot of
like the business section
we have a monday two pages of stat
content in the globe so
it has benefited to them whether i don't
know
it has been of benefit and you could
argue
separately that stat or no stat
there's been cutbacks at the globe right
anyway yeah all right
why don't we open it up um i have a
couple more questions but i want to make
sure you all get a chance to ask
questions as well uh so again make sure
you come up to the mic
and please do not be shy
someone always asks me yeah wait
oh and just again for the recording if
you could just identify yourself hi wade
rash from sts here at mit
um hey everybody so i'm curious about
what you're learning about rick you said
you're building your fan base right now
so who are you what are you learning
about who those people are and
i'm curious specifically about whether
uh how you think about the you you're
drawing in different types of audiences
right a lot of your stories are
very inside baseball like
pharmaceutical politics right
and others are
more about
disease treatments and seem to be
speaking to the families of of kids who
have specific conditions and and others
are about politics right and uh
the campaign trail and so
you're going after many different types
of readers and i'm curious where you're
seeing the response and whether you feel
that you can build a modern publication
around um
like a whole zoo of different types of
readers right so wait what are you going
after
see i would argue that that's what sets
us apart that um if you look at some
other general interest
publications that cover some of these
areas there's they're a little
they're more narrowly focused and we are
embracing
stories on the intersection of popular
culture and science politics and science
but we're not afraid to write about
the science of it and the more the the
more
um
sort of technical or more narrow issues
or about people's human life life
experiences and we have this column
called endnotes about the end of life
it's a very human
type of um
of approach i guess what i would say is
i mean you raise a fair good point and
um what we are finding so far from the
early metrics is
that
people
um first of all our audience is about 25
international
it's um
do you know what the is that what what
what's the globe stat for that i assume
that that's
it's i don't know i assume it's much
lower so we have international audiences
is that higher than you expected
i didn't really yeah yeah i think that's
impressive yeah it's so it's um and we
have um
the the biggest state we have is
massachusetts i think because we're
based here because the globe connection
and then
uh california and then new york but it's
pretty much scheduled uh we have readers
in every state except i think north
dakota i think there's like zero or
something but um
um and in terms of
demographics we're finding
a
more male than i expected
like a majority male and i don't i'm not
sure why that is
um it's also younger than i expected i
don't have the numbers offhand but it
was um
um
yeah like
most readers seem to be
30s or 40s or 20 you know just
um there are very few retirees or like
five percent or something of our
rebecca's age
and and um a lot of people who are in um
a lot of students which i get to be
think of medical students business
people
um
um
again i don't i
i don't have it in front of me but um
but one thing that has surprised me in
terms of what people want to read like i
thought um
i did like i had us do a story on
um
um
charlie sheen's doctor when charlie
sheen
um
said that he was hiv positive i think
it's dad's
obligation who else is going to sit down
in hollywood with sheen's
doctor and write a profile and i thought
that would get a lot of attention
that didn't it did okay but not great
because i think people are coming to us
for
more the science and the health i think
people aren't necessarily trained to
come to us
for
necessarily
um
the popular culture stuff that said is i
don't know the answer of whether like
i i think it's way too early for us to
react to what people
want i think we have to trust our gut
in just offering interesting stories and
see where that takes us and i'm sort of
happy with
this sort of buffet of interesting
stories rather than um like we had a
story
that ellie dulgin did about um
what was that micro sound like the thing
today microcondia yeah mitochondria no
no yeah yeah yeah and that to me was a
very like you have to he has the guy who
wrote our newsletter is a phd and like
he's you've got to know this stuff to
write about it and i thought this is
really authoritative and really
interesting
but i also thought well get an audience
that was one of our most popular stories
today because i think people are going
to us for serious stories
but also
our story on
um bernie sanders or returning his
donation from martin grelli before we
even launched went viral so
we just don't it's kind of too early to
tell we're trying to hit
business stories science stories um
sort of consumer not consumer but
patient stories
and we are one thing we're trying to
avoid is
health policy per se because i think too
many there's plenty of places to go for
that
um for for like the latest obamacare
twist
everyone loves a good mitochondria story
hi uh i'm david chandler i'm now at the
mit news office but i spent 16 years at
the boston globe health and science
section
and so i'm really curious about this new
model and
how
how it differs from what we used to do
in the health and science section and
what
what this new framework allows you to do
that's
different a lot of the pieces are the
same a lot of the elements are the same
you say you have you know
two pages in the monday paper we had
three pages in the monday paper uh all
of us who worked on the section you know
also wrote for the daily paper we had
stories coming out every day
all of our stories also ran online on
boston.com
all of the individual pieces seem very
similar
so i'm really curious about this new
model i'm i'm quite excited about it i
think this is fascinating and very
promising but i'm really curious about
what it is that this new structure this
new framework
enables what it lets you do that's
different than
than what happens under
the more traditional framework of
you know back when the the global health
and science
section was thriving there were dozens
of similar sections in newspapers all
around the country they've all gone away
except for the new york times section
pretty much now but
what do you what do you get out of this
new structure what does it give you what
does it let you do yeah no that's a very
good question and probably the best
person to answer would be gideon gill
who's our managing editor for
enterprise who you probably worked with
at the globe who went from he's the one
person went from the globe to stat um
and um so i
i wasn't at the globe i've only
been doing this for x amount of time so
i'm not the best
uh person to answer that on the other
hand i can tell you
um
what i do think it's
it's there's a liberating um
um
you're liberated from the requirements
of
a print
news organization and i found this at
politico when i went from the new york
times to politico i mean at the times i
was very involved in us moving toward
the web and digital and but
it's nothing is like being i go to
politico and nothing's like it like you
don't
your world is not geared around
um
delivery and print and writing headlines
to fit a certain
um space and writing a story to fit a
certain
space you can
think of an idea
ask for the story and and there it is on
the site you know in a flash an hour and
two hours you don't have to go through
the bureaucracy and what i would say is
if
there's a nimbleness that i think you
have to have to be competitive
in um and certainly in any new digital
enterprise but to be in journalism so
you have to be
fast and quick and able to turn things
around in a creative way
and
um i could just say from a purely
bureaucratic point of view had
had the money that was taken for stat
gone to the globe let's say if john
henry said let's rebuild
the globe's coverage and put all that
money in
um into stat there's no way
that
in x amount of months we could have
hired dozens and dozens of people it's
just impossible because that's not how
the world works and the culture and the
bureaucracy of any
any traditional news organization no
matter how well intended or no matter
what the quality we can move on things
and we can push things out
we can design beats and ways of coverage
that may seem like they've been done
before but but we we don't have to
think about any old ways of doing things
or ways that were done before we can
experiment and create and probably the
biggest
uh
difference and something carl talked
about is
multimedia i mean
stat i would say like
maybe 20 of 25 percent of our newsroom
is
geared to multimedia data visualization
animation
storytelling that's not text driven
and that's
totally different from
the new york times watching well maybe
they're watching both now boston globe
any traditional news organization and
that's the that's probably the the
biggest difference i i mean just to add
to that i mean i
you know i write every week for the new
york times i've written for them i guess
10 years now and i write for magazines
and
other places and you know different each
place has a different
um
kind of culture and style and newspapers
you know you write things for newspapers
in in a certain way
you know and there
i i go to the times with certain ideas
and i write about them in sort of the
times style so and if i don't it gets
that certain way i mean how how would
you describe the difference there not
you know not
not that much of a personal voice you
know just sort of like you know you can
sort of like you know you can have a
sense of humor you can you know uh you
can be graceful with your language but
it's got to be kind of within like okay
you're you're writing for the times like
that's how they do it and that's fine
and i have no qual with it it's a great
place to write about you know other
areas of science but
then at a place like stat um
you know like um
it's just different there are things
that i'm the things that i've been
proposing to stat
that i just i would just would not have
proposed to the science times or the
health section of the new york times so
like like what okay so like
um
just case in point so like okay so
i'm on
i'm kind of addicted to twitter so i'm
on twitter and
kind of kind of yeah and so i something
sort of flashes up about someone's
talking about
craig venter
you know genome pioneer he's got this
big hot shot company out in california
and he's making all these claims about
sequencing your genome and it's going to
be great for your health blah blah and
it's going to be the sort of 20 000
concierge health exam and so i'm like
that
you know so i'm just like i think i'm
skeptical
as are you know lots of people for good
reason many good reasons and i know that
you know craig venter is on twitter so
like i just say basically like tweeted
like
okay craig venture like how is this not
gonna be you know just a whole kind of
banquet of false positives you know
just come on and he emailed he need an
email i'm sorry he on twitter he just
said like that's very naive of you you
know
and i was like okay well so i so i went
to jason and i was like okay greg winner
just called me naive jason
jason uckman who's my editor at stat
like craig renner just called me naive
you know so do you mind if i write an
article about what they're doing
and so like like that i was writing an
article um you know there was no like
running in a flagpole or whatever like i
was on it and i was just working on it
and it was a very sort of like and so
was that was that the germ of the
article or was that part of the article
was that was your exchange with craig i
don't think i ended up mentioning it in
there but it was just sort of i just was
like
hey come on and you know like there are
certain places where you would have to
like laboriously work up a proposal and
you would have to go around a bunch of
people and get scored about whether they
can do it or not i was like let's just
do this and
and it was a
it felt more like a magaziney piece
there were people being very sort of
like this is i mean she's my french but
essentially saying this is [ __ ] you
know and ventre being like hey like you
know they don't get it you know like it
was a very
just you know very brightly colored
story and i could do it at stat i don't
i don't think i would try to write it
for a straight newspaper but the and for
for people who haven't worked in
newspapers so the a difference there
uh between what would happen in the
newspaper is you'd need to see if there
was room in the next day's paper it
would need to go to the page one meeting
or to the section meeting and
a couple hours later you might get a
decision and that may or may not be too
late you're on it you're you're on an
aircraft carrier right right right
does that make sense i mean
it's it still seems nebulous in that i'm
i'm not sure that i couldn't have
proposed a story like that
uh for the print paper but i but i see
your point that there's certainly
my experience and let me give you an
example that i can say
or as a sense very directly um there are
many stories we do for stat
that we offer to the globe
that they run three or four days later
and
and we love that when they do it we
pitch them to
and um but they have to it has to go
through a process like any
traditional news or it has to go through
do we have the space what's it competing
against what is the um can we put it in
our
content management system that work
works we have to write the headline for
it there's a copy editing there's a
process
so routinely they're stories that we've
had in stat and again
we have a certain benefit of being
smaller and we could just put up what we
want to put up when but there is a
certain fleet-footedness that you have
in a purely digital news organization
where you can get things out and i'll
give you one example like we started
this thing a week or two ago called that
every day runs it's a zika in 30 seconds
and the whole idea is what you need to
know about zika and it's a way of
showing that we want to own this
coverage we do a lot of in-depth deeper
stories we have this
uh guy that's been in colombia writing
stories we have a video a series
starting tomorrow from brazil but we
want to show that like if you need a
quick fix
here's where to go and um
and
i said like i said let's just do this
and there's some people that said like
should we do it or not do it if i'd been
at the new york times it was like taking
like weeks to like figure it out and go
up the flagpole i said let's at first i
said let's do it zika in 60 seconds and
then i said no let's make it 30 seconds
it's just like you know you can just try
things and it happens immediate and
there's a sense of we're on it in a
sense of news urgency that's always
important in the print world but it's
even more important in the digital world
that we can do i think i mean just
just again to broaden it out i mean
just to talk you know we're talking
about like the future of
science journalism here and and i
um
i i don't see things as going from you
know
like a you know a certain set of
publications they all disappear and
they're replaced by things like staff
that's not going to happen
um
and you know there are unquestionably
like big advantages to different
kinds of formats so like
you know if you want to go really
extreme you know you can go to something
like national geographic magazine
so there
like
you can
propose a piece if you like go from the
time that you you know i've gone through
this and other people have as well if
you were to like put a pin on when you
know you and your editor first kind of
started talking about a story when it
finally came out you could be talking
three years i'm not kidding at all at
all i'm not kidding at all and when it
comes down it might be average right i
mean you could go much longer three
years oh my god i'm not kidding and what
comes out is gorgeous because like they
they basically say now we're going to
take a photographer and send them out
for six months to just like take
thousands of pictures and and we're
gonna we're gonna you know we will do
the most beautiful
story out there about this and we're
gonna we're gonna work really hard in
the pros as well and that's fantastic
uh and and i you know that's going to
still be around that's going to stick
around but it's going to be
um and they're thinking you know stat
can't really do that
your lips to rupert's ears yeah like
well yeah well we'll see what rupert
murdoch thinks about all that but you
know but they will be sort of making
room for things like stat
that's my prediction so rebecca um
speaking of pieces that might not have
run uh
um in the paper but something that got
picked up uh by a lot of places
you had another shkreli story besides
the bernie one
uh what can you describe that the about
with his with his feed
sure so um the
bernie sanders donation um or the martin
shkreli's donation to bernie sanders
which bernie sanders ultimately returned
was not a story i did one of my
colleagues did but
relatively early in the
hubbub over martin shkreli
i
wrote a piece um that
as many story ideas are are now inspired
was inspired just by being on twitter
and and seeing him post occasionally in
fact frequently actually posting links
to a
live stream that he he was doing on
uh youtube and other sites and so i
started watching um out of out of
curiosity does everyone know who martin
shkreli is the
evil marvel comic
villain so i started watching his his uh
live stream and this was this was in
november so it was sort of
after he had um gained notoriety but
before he was arrested on on charges
of um
securities fraud and so
the
um piece that i did while he was sort of
at the
rising in the public consciousness was
on this
sort of bizarre and fascinating live
stream that he was doing of himself
sitting in his pajamas playing guitar
playing chess playing video games
and so
now you know after after he was arrested
and
in recent weeks a lot of folks have done
stories on on his live stream
so i think one advantage that that stat
had was was to um be pa having uh
reporters paying attention to those sort
of things early on
and you can certainly make arguments uh
one way or another about the the value
of a piece like that you know it may not
have advanced the serious public policy
debate about about drug pricing but what
i think
we're
encouraged to devalue and what editors
at stat value
is the
you know human side of stories and it's
certainly fascinating and telling of
our 2015 into now 2016 uh world that
the
pharmaceutical executive who is at the
center of this
hubbub over over high drug prices is
spending you know 10 hours a day online
live streaming his his everyday
moves and you know sitting in his office
at work and that kind of insight that
live real-time window
into
his thinking and his
in some cases rambling i think is is
fascinating and we saw value news value
there as well
um other yeah jenny
hi jenny rood i am a writer at the bread
institute um i wanted to go back to
something that you spoke about earlier
which was you know filling this need
for this kind of coverage and in
addition to the the wonderful variety of
topics that you cover in the the health
and life sciences fields um one of the
things i think is really fascinating
about stat is the variety of the columns
so i mean
carl's videos or
sharon bakely's gut check or you know to
have the retraction watch um ivan
aranski and adam marcus writing
about you know
problems with scientific publications
and to have that all under one roof so
my question is
um
how early in the conception of stat did
you have ideas for things that you
wanted to be regular columns and then
obviously you have things that pop up
after zach after
set has launched like zika that you've
decided you know this is something we're
gonna do every day or concussions we're
going to do a regular series on
um
what
it kind of all just came together i
think one thing
perhaps
my biggest fear at the beginning
was
knowing how sensitive and complicated
this kind of coverage can be
and especially speaking from someone who
doesn't have this background i was
worried that
we would
we would not be credible and
um
i mean i wasn't like losing sleepover
but i wanted to make sure we were
credible and so we hired
editor we had a mix of editors but
editors who knew what they were talking
about who could identify
like is this a bogus study or is this
not or what's the proper way to describe
this story and there's a tension again
between
making like we're pushing out things to
be we want to be
like ahead of the game on stories and we
there's no um
um there's no room to be
um
to get beat by anyone on any story so
i'm eager to be ahead of the game and
give added value content whether it's on
shkreli's live streaming or whether
something more serious about um
the developments with zika and um
so there's this tension between being
fast and nimble and quick but also
being accurate and right and part of
that
way we're able so far knock on wood to
be able to do that is to have
authorities in their fields
as
a important part of our coverage from
carl to helen branswell who
covers infectious disease who came who
moved here from canada to to be our uh
one of our senior writers to sharon
bagley who came from reuters moved from
new york to
to join us we've had
to my
delight
a lot of people who have taken a risk to
join a brand new startup who've given up
secure jobs or would seem to be
secure jobs that the wall street journal
new york times washington post reuters
bloomberg politico
so they've a huge group and people that
are
that are
knowledgeable and respected
from the get-go then you layer over that
some of the most talented um
uh
younger journalists of their generation
and i put rebecca at the top of the list
and we have some of the best and
brightest around the country so that mix
just brings a great energy and authority
to our coverage
more yep
hi uh my name is frankie shembree and
i'm an undergraduate here at mit
studying science writing um and as
someone who kind of wants to break into
the field
what do you think sort of sets apart a
great reporter from a good reporter in
science writing especially in this
century
um
uh
i i think um
i can i think
you know a problem is
a problem that science writing faces is
more so than other kinds of
journalism is kind of a
sort of a pack mentality and everybody
going sort of obediently like following
the same press release you know and and
writing it up and basically all telling
the same story
and you know sometimes sometimes you got
to do it you know so today was
gravitational waves i mean everyone's
got to write their gravitational wave
story that's fine
um but
you know which
you know like which of those hundred
gravitational wave stories was the one
to read i honestly i don't know
but i do know like i like to read dennis
overby so i'll read his because i know
about him already because he's developed
a voice and he's written about things
that i haven't seen elsewhere
so i think
you know i think what science writers
really need to do
to to to make names for themselves is to
wean themselves from the press release
from the embargo system from being told
by press
offices what to write about and to find
the stories themselves and just and you
know and look for good stories so
um
and you got to be sort of asking
yourself about that i mean you might be
like
you know rebecca may be like looking for
something to be looking around and being
like whoa wait a minute like this is
weird and important and no one has seen
this before and i'm going to write about
it or you just
i don't know like i mean rick mentioned
this story i wrote about the scientist
named slava epstein
his stuff's been written about before um
it's not like a scoop or anything like
that it's just that
um
i just sort of you know i he and i had
spoken on the phone and he just sounded
like a really interesting person and so
i wanted to meet him so i hung out with
him and i was like this guy is
just got such a strange story like he
was a scientist in the soviet union who
was just you know basically like he was
jewish and so they he was a marine
biologist and he's like they're not
going to let me get on a boat because i
think i'm going to escape next the first
port we get to but you know of course
you're saying this all and it's
wonderful
yeah right it's like but you know like
why you know it's fine i don't want to
be you know on a boat with some drunk
captain who's going to just destroy my
experiments i'll just sit on the beach
and do my research there oh you know
like that he's that kind of a guy and
then he comes to america and he works
the night shift at a parking garage you
know and then like goes on to like
discover antibiotics and no one else is
found and i'm like
that's a story it's not i'm not like
writing off of a press release like i
found a story and so
that you know
i think that's the main way to sort of
like kind of make people recognize who
you are as a science writer because
otherwise
if they look at your cv and they're like
yeah okay you you got that press release
too okay fine whatever
to build a little bit on what carl said
there are
um many many more good writers than
there is space to print good writers
virtually or
in the physical world um that is not
true of reporters so uh if you're trying
to figure out what to focus on focus on
reporting um uh you know
thinking about the stories that that
we've been talking about here that have
made a mark they're all
they're not all uh but a lot of them are
stories that no one else had seen
or no one else had made the calls uh you
know that is theranose cook that's um
what an old boss a man used to call like
a scoop of analysis
but it's coming at it and making the
calls
but that's the one thing that i see
more than anything else
when people are sort of frustrated
about
where they're going with their career or
what their prospects are um there's
always uh a need for good journalists
and if you have a story that no one else
has
there will always be someone who will
pay you for it
hi i'm jane roberts i'm the associate
editor of undark which is a new science
magazine
starting at ksj
i was interested in
learning more about the native
advertising i was interning at forbes
before and that's a big part of their
strategy but wondering if you've
actually
you know how far you are along in the
process of deciding who you would allow
to advertise on your site and if you
think
that will affect the way that your
readers see you and your credibility
um i
i i should
the person really should address this as
our revenue officer um but but in
general um
um for example i i don't think
we we haven't gotten any kind of
pushback from anyone about our
advertising or in our native advertising
or our in our morning rounds we've
started running
very sponsored by
j or whatever and we've gotten
i think we got like
um
three
emails from people complaining or
something but people are kind of used to
that as long as it's clearly
marked and in terms of sponsored content
we've
begun
to do that in um on our site and again
it's clearly labeled and we and i'd have
to
um
defer to angus about what we might not
use or but but we're certainly
um there's certainly certain basic
principles of if if we with any
advertiser if there's something that we
think is
false or wrong or misleading or whatever
there's certain advertising standards in
what we'll run but in terms of clearly
marked
um
sponsored ad native ads i don't i i
think that's you're going to see more
and more of it um
whether it's stat or other news
organizations you know
the new york times is talking about the
washington post just that's just
the way of the world
and let me just say there's things that
are happening
now that if you had asked me
10 years ago or like oh my god native
advertising
or
an ad in
front of page front pages and i'm i was
at the new york times debate we cannot
have ads on the front page of the new
york times i remember arthur solzberg
was the publisher saying we will never
have an ad i remember saying we will
never have an ad on the front page of
the new york times boy just the whole
world we've all seen it has um has so
changed
he also told me once that uh he wasn't
worried about the internet because
people couldn't read the paper in the
bathroom on their computers
other uh other questions
all right yes in the back
yeah
you need to
so i'm carrie o'brien i'm a public
relations specialist at worcester
polytechnic institute um what's your
process for finding original content
maybe besides twitter
it does sort of seem like that's the
main reporting tool the main thing i've
been hearing
yeah so i i can answer that as as a
reporter always on the hunt for story
ideas um
i
definitely
find my
stories from a variety of places some of
it is is social media and what i'm
seeing a conversation about but i find
stories from just reading other
news pieces that other reporters have
done perhaps you know lying in a story
will will tip me off that there's
something more there
other times just in a conversation with
a source about a different topic or in
you know just a conversation to check in
about what they're doing
they'll mention something that triggers
an idea
and in some cases too um press people
have pitched me
ideas that
i'll say oftentimes the specific pitch
um
that tends to be a little more
incremental i don't ultimately run with
but um there there have been there have
been instances where an element of a
pitch might from from a press person
might inspire us to take a different
approach or a broader approach
to something that gets pitched
so
in some i would say
looking
in as many places as possible and and
for for both of you too um do you uh
um do you ever make calls and just sort
of call around and say what do you got
call to
your sources oh sure oh yeah no i'm
as much as i can yeah absolutely yeah
because
you know you want to find out what's
what's going on and and maybe there's
something that's sitting there
just hiding in plain view um and um some
you know sometimes i mean um
you know i i deal a lot with public
information officers and
but
you know if they're like saying like
you know but but i i sometimes i have to
sort of explain to them like how our
interaction can be useful to me you know
so if they
contact me at 9 00 a.m
on a tuesday and say hey i've got a
press release about a gigantic
complicated paper that's going to be
coming out at two o'clock today
i'll be like
you know
okay great so there's going to be a huge
amount of superficial coverage of this
and i don't have the time right now to
write the kind of story i'd want so
that's not you're not helping me um and
i'll just sort of be honest about it um
or like with these with science it
happens with a video series like i just
i would go to places and i talk to
people and be like okay like i'm looking
for people
and you know that maybe i could visit
and and here here's what i need you know
i need to go someplace where people are
not afraid of the camera
they actually want to talk and maybe
they have some you know maybe we can
like
do stuff look at things you know it's
not just sort of anonymous sort of beige
boxes and
uh so can you help me with that and you
know sometimes they'll like say like oh
here's the list of our top
hot scientists and be like well that's
that's not what i asked you for and so
let's try that again you know um
so it it that that's a big part of it it
does take it does take work and you know
a lot of what i do is just like talk to
sort of a network of scientists and be
like what's going on out there like were
you just at a meeting did you see
something at that meeting that i should
know about
that's how i do it and i'll add on to
that um
i think as carl alluded to earlier the
pac mentality that you sometimes see in
in science journalism can create a
situation where if a researcher hasn't
put out a paper in the past two years
no one's written about her for the past
two years and so i have that situation
with um
a researcher working on on
a topic i was very interested in which
is medication adherence
and he had been doing some some very
interesting work that was written about
two years ago and previously but no one
had written a thing since then so i got
on the phone with him and he's been very
busy and his technology has been adopted
all over the place in
a way that is actually making a
meaningful impact in clinics and to
patients
but because he hasn't put out a paper in
that time period when in fact his
research is
making news in a meaningful way nobody's
been writing about it so i think that
those are the kind of stories um that
are
independent of
press releases or sort of the
manufactured news events that the
release of a paper can represent um that
we're interested in and always trying to
chase yeah big those big papers or it
can be like people can make such a
fetish of them
they're such a fiction you know that
that's what it's all about you know
those are that's just like sort of
putting out sort of formal
presentation of some results but it's
not you know that's not
the world doesn't revolve around the
paper
so before we go i just want to ask um uh
each of you uh one last question so um
rebecca
you uh
you're two years out of school
um when you talk to your peers who are
at other who are at newspapers or
websites or other
who are working in other areas of
journalism um
is there anything that strikes you as
being sort of fundamentally different
about what you're doing in your
experience than than some of them and if
so what
that's a good question um
my friends who are uh working in
journalism are not working in science
journalism um and so
uh i think the reaction that i get from
a lot of my friends who are
working in in other fields of
journalism is that sounds really hard
and complicated
particularly because i you know i don't
have a science background um i was a
history major in college um and so what
i have
said to them is is that um
i really approach
this um first foray that i am in in
science journalism the way i would with
with any other stories which is uh why
does this matter and
how can i explain it and regulate the
most interesting and important elements
in in a way that's accessible and how do
i how do i get to the important and good
story and i don't think that's different
for for science journalism as opposed to
other other fields so i think
what stat my experience at stat um has
given me that perhaps other
peers that i i know are at other
publications might not have is i think
to some degree access to
a great multimedia team as rick has
talked about
and the capabilities that we have there
but i think also the opportunity to
really specialize and get to know this
field well
has has been something valuable
um and
carl for a non-stat question
i'm curious about where you are finding
the most um interesting long-form
journalism outside of stat
what types of places uh what types of
outlets i know there's been a lot of a
lot of places that have either started
doing that recently or have actually um
started from scratch so i'm curious
about
um yeah i mean i i forage pretty widely
um
you know what's nice is that with
um with science
there are places
uh like stat that have a lot of
specialization on it but there are like
a lot of general interest places as well
that uh have sort of recognized
the importance of it um
it being science science and medicine
zone you know the new yorker has been
doing some really good stuff in the past
few years i mean on rare diseases
especially well yeah
yeah that's right so you got if you
haven't read seth's piece in the new
yorker go check it out um and and but
the thing is like the fact is that i
would say like 10 years ago like the new
yorker had
relatively little i was like maybe you
know john mcphee talking about
earthquakes i mean that's about it or
oranges yeah oranges whatever but you
know now it's like you know they they
had a you know michael specter wrote a
great big piece on crisper which was i
thought was really excellent so the new
yorker has been doing a great job the
new year comes magazine has been um
really starting to pull its own weight
um and so these are general interest uh
places that are doing science and i
think that's great because
you know and and i think what it's it
you know you don't want science to sort
of fall into just like a little
niche somewhere that only people who
self-identify as well i like to read
about science read about it
and so you know the fact that there are
people at stat who do not have a very
sort of narrow sort of science or
medicine reporting background i think
it's fantastic because we don't want a
narrow audience we want a broad one you
know so
um
and uh rick uh
is has it been a year or a little less
yeah i came here like late february of
last year so i think i ran into you not
not that long ago you were here um and
we were talking about how you sort of
didn't know what to expect i mean it was
you know both in terms of subject matter
and also it seemed like something that
um uh to some extent it was like you
know stepping off a a
and you were interested to find out what
would happen maybe a cliff isn't the
best analogy because there's only one
thing really that might happen when you
step off a cliff um uh but closing our
eyes and and and making the leap of
faith um so now a year out i'm curious
as to what uh has surprised you um
what's been radically different than
what you expected uh what's been
frustrating what's been satisfying
um i i guess what i would say is that um
it's like you know it was this whole new
world of not knowing what to
expect and never having done a startup
before and
um
um what's
um
and and not knowing
how it's gonna be or what form it will
take or who will do it with you it's
just it's been a whole mystery um um but
i've what i what's been great about it
is i've just learned so much not only
about the field but about
building an
organization and building a company and
what it takes and things you don't think
about
um and i've i guess what i would say
the
the the most
surprising and gratifying part of it is
i didn't really
i i said earlier i was a little i was
worried about our credibility but
i didn't realize the extent to which
that there really seems to be a hunger
for
what we're doing and a real like
dedication of people saying i swear to
you and i just sounds like i'm just
promoting us which i am but it's like
every day i swear to you every day
i get
a tweet or email or for some someone
saying thank we're so grateful you're
doing this or i just heard you're doing
this it happens every single day and i
never really
anticipated that and it's been nice to
see
the interest and i think because
um again someone like me from a
political background there's a million
sites and publications and newsletters
on like the campaign
or
and it's nice to have
um be able to cover an area that's so
important
that where there is an opening where
there is an opportunity and it touches
every it touches everyone like i feel
like
on the one hand i don't have the
specialization but on the other hand
these are stories that matter to to all
of us
and and i think the trick is um
as you said is uh to to have deep good
reporting and be aggressive with
reporting but also
um in a way i mean carl has made a mark
for years in in making science
accessible and
and pulling people in and a lot of
people can't do that so it's been a lot
of
the fun
it's been fun for me learning this
building this
bringing people in and what's really
cool about a startup as opposed to
anywhere else i've worked is
i can pick everyone that i want to work
with and every single hire is someone
that
we vetted through a process
um and i would say pound-for-pound
person for me that carefully well look
what happened
but person per person these are
um um
the it's the most talented collection of
editors and reporters that i've worked
with because
you know you say oh you're at the new
york times but there are times like you
inherit different people and people come
different ways but here you can start
anew with the very best people that make
a sort of dynamic team
and just and just one thing that's
that's kind of fun is the mixing and
matching carl's
editor purposely is
was we hired from the washington post he
was deputy national security editor at
the new york at the post no background
in this
in this field whatsoever and i l but a
great reputation as an editor and i love
that because we don't need carl doesn't
need an editor who knows more than
science and he does he needs just a
great editor and so i love seeing
seeing these combinations work and the
other thing that i would say that's been
a surprise to me is
that
i thought the hard part would be
launching the site
the hard part and it was like
all-consuming and busy for all of us but
it's it gets harder as you go along it's
it's and it's fun and invigorating but
my job is harder and i don't know
how you all would see it but
we're now up and running and now there's
like the demands of a real news
organization every day where challenges
come up and things we need to do and how
do we build the audience and how do we
um
like we're very i'm very restless we're
all very restless because we want to
establish ourselves even more it's never
enough we want to get out there and be
known and do good stuff i want to be out
when i saw this new york times zika
uh big
takeout over the on sunday i thought why
i didn't even think of doing that and
and so we were so there's challenges
every day to be journalistically
competitive so it's it's harder but it's
it's fun to have the challenge and let
me if i may take
one minute because part of the challenge
i have
is to be sort of a huckster for what
we're we're doing and i would say most
of you said you know you you see stat or
reads that but it takes we're trying to
build an audience organically person by
person you can't just you know we had
advertising
on the new york times website didn't do
a thing for our for
our that i saw for our traffic because
it's got to be person to person building
the audience and we're gaining an
audience every day you know it creeps up
but i would ask you
to if you haven't already to sign up for
morning rounds which is free on the site
because um it's really a great window
into what we do every day
6 a.m every morning and also
um
if you
um if you're on twitter or facebook to
like us or follow us because really it's
just building person per person
building an audience and so far i'm very
grateful for what for for the audience
and for these international readers but
um but i won't be satisfied until
it just gets bigger and more and and
bigger and bigger and where we can start
um
supporting ourselves
uh one word answer
um uh who uh has uh thinner skin
politicians or scientists
yeah yeah no i wouldn't have carl's
never politicians
i don't know about politics i would say
scientists because they're not used to
the coverage
in the in that
way
i would agree
all right there you go
uh thank you guys so much for coming
let's give a huge round of applause carl
came down from connecticut rebecca and
rick both have um
uh a ton of work to do thank you guys so
much for joining us
and
the this will be posted online within
the next couple of days